j'ai une opération à l'agent
de parkinson puis on avait besoin
d'aménagements là y'avait pas de feuille
adapter la salle de bains mais si ça
devenait compliqué pour demeurer chez
lui pierre lavallée a dû faire adapter
sa maison qu'il partage avec sa femme
muriel lizotte en 2016 le couple dépose
une demande pour bénéficier du programme
d'adaptation de domicile du gouvernement
du québec communément appelé le pad un
ergonome vient évaluer les besoins on
prépare ensuite les plans et devis ils
obtiennent le feu vert pour lancer les
travaux un an et demi plus tard
ici tout change pas si l'entrepreneur
alain croteau qui effectue les travaux
il refait entièrement la salle de bain
pour que pierre puissent y accéder un
fauteuil roulant douche sans seuil
barres d'appui nouvelle vanité dépasser
25 mille dollars salle de bain c'est pas
long c'est pas long par contre gap tout
cas ce qu'affirme une chambre à coucher
est aménagé au rez-de-chaussée pour
pierre trois cadres de portes sont
élargies si on exclut les extras demandé
par le couple comme une plateforme
élévatrice la facture totale grimpe à 50
mille dollars
il n'est pas nous a donné ça venait
c'est sûr que c'était nettement
insuffisant dans notre corps
la société d'habitation du québec gère
le programme depuis 30 à l'aide
financière de base qui est de 16 mille
dollars n'a jamais été indexé des
montants supplémentaires sont cependant
offert aux personnes à faibles revenus
et celles qui ont besoin d'équipements
spécialisés le gouvernement
oblige un des normes
pour le programme pâte
mais d'un bon financement privé quand
j'ai commencé en 98 les clients paient
en 2000 et 5000 de ses poches
aujourd'hui on parle de
dans une déclaration le cabinet de la
ministre de l'habitation andré la forêt
indique qu'elle souhaite bonifier encore
davantage les subventions offertes pour
que les coûts d'adaptation soit encore
mieux couverts mais sans offrir plus de
détails dans les cinq dernières années
plus de dix mille personnes ont déposé
une demande jugée admissible par le pad
mais 37 % des dossiers sont abandonnés
en cours de route certains demandeurs
décide par exemple de déménager quand
des travaux pour adapter leurs maisons
sont trop importants d'autres n'ont pas
assez d'argent on l'a payé une partie à
longueuil c'est sûr que la moitié des
projets qui marchent ils sortent à peu
près 42 aussi par année le jury 20 km h
ils vont qu'ils abandonnent leur projet
depuis 2000 vers montréal c'est la ville
qui gère le programme d'adaptation
domiciliaire l'aide financière maximale
de 35 mille dollars donc deux fois plus
élevé qu'ailleurs dans la province
marie-chantal salle vasse est devenu
tétraplégique après un accident lors
d'un voyage son conjoint et elle ont dû
acheter une nouvelle propriété et
l'adapter 150 $ pour une coupe de cadres
de porc une telle forme élévatrice une
salle de bains a grandi d'un porte de
garage
du souffle à elle avait entamé des
démarches pour bénéficier du pad mais a
finalement laissé tomber parce qu'il y
avait deux ans d'attentes à l'époque
pour cette mère de famille ça ne venait
pas le coup d'attendre aussi longtemps
pour une subvention de 16 mille dollars
injectés problème c'est forcément un
accident mais je trouve ça dommage que
s'il avait eu un accident de la route a
été payée ou à fond pour cent
pratiquement elle espère que le
programme d'adaptation domiciliaire sera
revu
on considère l'inflation depuis 992 on
regarde le coût réel des travaux de
grande 42 de subventions aujourd'hui
airs qu'on se parle ça serait pas
exagéré si on veut que les gens restent
à la maison fou pour m'encourager
ouais vous donner les moyens qui vont
avec